l' ocde définit la classe moyenne comme
étant les personnes dont le revenu après
impôt et transferts se situe entre 75 et
200 pour cent du revenu médian au québec
en 2010 est le revenu médian était de 39
1500 $ ce qui veut dire que pour faire
partie de la classe moyenne il faut
gagner entre 29 1625 $ et soixante dix
neuf mille dollars pour un couple avec
deux enfants
il faut un revenu familial entre 59 et
cent cinquante huit mille dollars pour
faire partie de la classe moyenne
une étude publiée aujourd'hui par
l'observatoire québécois des inégalités
conclu que la classe moyenne se porte le
mieux au québec que dans le reste du
pays
entrevue avec nicolas dyon une directeur
général de l'observatoire québécois des
inégalités bonsoir alors une plus une
plus grande classe moyenne qu'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on voit présentement au
québec c'est donc dire que le québec est
moins inégalitaire
est ce qu'on peut dire ça le québec est
reconnu depuis plusieurs années comme
étant une société plus plus égalitaire
c'est andy on regarde la classe moyenne
on peut se poser la question est ce que
le constat est partagé également ce
niveau ce type d'inégalités comme on
peut dire on arrive au constat qu
effectivement la classe moyenne et les
plus importantes au québec que dans le
reste du canada près comme une société
dans son ensemble
une fois qu'on considère les peaux et
les transferts par contre pas ce constat
avant les impôts et les transfère sa
nature un peu surpris la classe moyenne
est de la même taille que le reste du
canada
alors c'est vraiment l'ensemble de l'âge
du changement s'explique par les impôts
et les transports sont plus importants
au québec ce qui est également une
distinctive ici alors ce qu'on voit donc
c'est que 43% de la population au québec
comme dans le reste du canada
43% quand on regarde les revenus bruts
font partie de la classe moyenne
mais quand on regarde le revenu net donc
l'intervention de l'état les impôts les
transferts l'on est à 61 % contre 57 %
ailleurs au canada
donc c'est vraiment l'intervention de
l'état c'est vraiment ça qu'ils
l'expliquent la différence la différence
à pourrait difficilement et plus est
plus clair mais en plus de thon peut
aussi
prendre en considération le revenu après
impôt et transporte le revenu net ce qui
nous reste dans nos poches une fois que
on a fini nos dépenses des dépenses que
qui reviennent qu'on paye des services
publics ou pas spécialement pour ce
réseau de l'éducation il ya une part qui
est déjà payée par l'impôt
ça coûte moins cher pour les personnes
qui en bénéficient ont pesé la même
chose
dodo type de service public comme les
garderies donc ses impôts ils servent
aussi à quelque chose puisse aussi cette
annonce des risques et même pas dans ce
portrait là donc ça se rajoute à
l'ensemble de ce portrait qui concerne
uniquement les impôts les transferts les
impôts et les transfère donc si on
ajoute et seuls 61 serait probablement
encore plus élevé par rapport au reste
du canada
effectivement bon autre graphique on va
regarder 7 en comparaison de l' ocde
quand on regarde le québec par rapport
aux autres pays de l' ocde le québec et
dansant vous voyez que 31% la population
font partie de ce qu'on appelle les
moins nantis 61% on le retrouve là c'est
la classe moyenne et 8% sont les mieux
nantis à 61 c'est mieux que les états
unis à 51
mais c'est moins bien que la france à 68
effectivement quand on regarde le
contexte nord-américain le québec et qui
se distingue clairement comme étant la
société la plus égalitaire en amérique
du nord et ce assez reconnus et qu'on y
compris pour serein pour cent le plus
riche mais également au niveau du taux
de pauvreté est ce qu'on voit dans les
données
ceci étant lorsqu'on le compare aux
autres pays de l' ocde le québec est
effectivement la moyenne et il fait
moins bonne figure que par exemple les
pays scandinaves ou même certains
certains pays d'europe
ceci étant je sais c'est important de
mentionner les classes moyennes sont
plus importantes dans les pays qui ont
plus d'impôts et de transfert donc c'est
vraiment ça qui explique la différence
ensuite des façons de distribuer
différemment mérites du pouce c'est une
bonne façon de d'avoir une idée la
classe moyenne grandit on n'a pas les
données à ce sujet une prochaine étude
on sait pas mais en fait il faut faire
le calcul à partir des données puis si
une chose qu'on voudrait savoir on
opposer beaucoup la question ces
derniers jours est ce que le
gouvernement trudeau à améliorer le sort
de la classe moyenne et données les plus
récentes disponibles sondages
2 il ya déjà deux ans alors pour pouvoir
avoir un portrait sur le long terme sur
l'évolution de la classe moyenne inclue
à pour ce gouvernement
il faut vraiment prendre encore non
seulement les données qui sont
disponibles mais aussi prendre en compte
le fait les politiques souvent ça prend
plusieurs années avant d'avoir leur
effet danlos aider la classe moyenne
grandi dans l'eau cdo les pays de l'osce
et durent en moyenne rétrécissant temps
de classe moyenne leurs classes moyennes
devient moins forte - moins importante
en fait elle se réduit
une des choses qu'ils l'expliquent de
l'augmentation des inégalités et une
partie des revenus qui sont tirés vers
le haut on ne les parisiens pour cent le
plus riche est un bon exemple mais aussi
le coût de la vie qui augmente davantage
dans plusieurs pays de l ocde
ceci étant le québec l'eau si on n'a pas
les données spécifiques là dessus on
sait que le québec se sentir mieux au
niveau du prix du logement par exemple
qui s'en tirent mieux au niveau du prix
de l'éducation de l'électricité de
l'assurance automobile tour des éléments
sur lesquels le québec intervient
directement ou indirectement mais
beaucoup de gens diraient et puis
l'aspect scientifique ce que je dis le
coût de la vie augmente on est endetté
il ya des pressions financières quand
même sur la classe moyenne
tout à fait je pensais le coût de la vie
augmente le revenu médian aussi et le
monde dont le soya à cet élément là
qu'il faut il faut tout de même prendre
en compte
par contre oui l'endettement là dessus à
ce niveau là il ya triplé dans les 30
dernières années pour l'ensemble des
ménages sont aussi faut le prendre en
compte donc s'épanouir un portrait qui
tout rose non plus on le voit
généralement dans l'est dans les
statistiques sur le 1 % la part des
revenus qui est capté par l'un pour cent
le plus riche et plus important
généralement un peu partout dans le
reste du canada aussi par rapport au
québec quelles sont les conséquences de
voir l'un pour s'enrichir davantage et
plus rapidement sur la classe moyenne
mais forcément c'est lorsqu'on prend le
revenu qui est générée par une société
il y en a davantage qui est capté par la
partie en haut de la pyramide est
forcément s'en laisse mon écharpe une
porte - grosse pour le reste de la
population
mais ça aussi des effets pervers on sait
que dans les sociétés plus inégalitaires
on regarde au sud de la frontière c'est
un bon exemple plus des inégalités
importantes par le haut
- le système politique et démocratique
mais il ya aussi des conséquences très
concrètes pour les gens par exemple
au niveau du logement lorsqu'il ya plus
de riches cet argent il l'est pas ils
veulent générer des rendements alors
qu'est ce qu'ils font l'investissement
en bourse
il va avoir plus de deux crises
financières de la cause de ça mais aussi
l'investissement qu'ils vont faire au
niveau du logement de l'habitation de
l'immobilier et sosa une pression vers
le haut pour le prix de l'ensemble des
logements et c'est aussi baisse à
l'impact sur la classe moyenne
directement et effectivement il ya des
limites toutefois votre études dites
vous oui parce que c'est d'une part
c'est important qu'ils statique c'est
juste une année on ne regardait les plus
récentes données de 2007 et pour la
définition de la fameuse classe moyenne
on vous en a donné une ce soir mais il y
en a d'autres qui existent et sont et
parfaites elles ont toutes des limites
notre façon de regarder la classe
moyenne c'est comment les gens se
perçoivent ou encore comment ce que le
niveau d'éducation ou le niveau de
profession ce que c'est des professions
qui sont associés à la classe moyenne
aux mines anti au monde entier nicholson
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci bien